[Müzik]
Merhabalar ben nesan Aydınoğlu şu anda
sizi görmüyorum daha önce böyle bir
sahneye de çıkmadım E buradan kimse
görmüyormuş Evet Merhabalar E ben nan
Aydınoğlu
H2 hsin kurucu ortaklarından
biriyim şf Şimdi bundan sonraki Aslında
bu Evet Eee daha çok Beni buradan
tanıyorsunuz Aslında beni tanımıyorsunuz
Muhtemelen oyunumuzu biliyorsunuz Eee
kelimelik oyunun yapımcılarından biri
olma sebebiyle bugün bu kırmızı noktada
yer alıyorum Eee Aslında kelimelik
birçok yaşanmışlığın ardından çıkmış bir
ürün Onun için ben sizi hikayenin en
başına götürmek
istiyorum ama
zorlanıyorum
eee Ben 97 yılında Hacettepe istatistik
bölümüne neredeyse rastgele girdim
diyebilirim o sene yaşadığım bazı
talihsiz sağlık problemleri sebebiyle
üniversite sınavına çok odaklanamıyorum
ama Üniversiteye de girmek zorunda
olduğum bir sene geçirdim Eee iş böyle
olunca işte Hacettepe istatistik
bölümünü kazandım ama aslında Senenin
başında e mimarlıkta hedefim yine Hiç
bilmediğim başka bir meslek Eee ben
böyle işte otti mimarlıkta okumayı
yani çok hevesliydim
Sonra işte yani Hani bizim zamanımızda
biraz işler böyleydi o zaman meslekler
hakkında en ufacık bir fikrimiz yoktu ne
olacağımızı bilmiyorduk bir bölümü
sadece işte aldığımız puanı en iyi
şekilde değerlendirmek puan boşa
gitmesin deyip İşte en iyi yere girmeye
çalışıyorduk ama o bölümün çıktıktan
sonra bize uygun olup olmayacağını
Bilemezdik
E neyse işte benim elimde bir referansım
vardı matematiğe olan sevgim ve ben bu
sevgiyle istatistiği yazdım bir
rehberlik hocası bana böyle bir şey
söylemişti yazdım girdim
e ilk sene yine
geldim ilk sene sevgili eşim aynı
zamanda İş ortağım Deniz'le tanıştım
Deniz o zaman bile bir bilgisayar
kuruydu ortaokuldan beri program yazan
her türlü programlamayla ilgilenen işte
bilgisayarla
ilgilenen hayatta ne olacağını çok
önceden çözmüş aramızdaki şanslı biriydi
Eee Ben henüz o zamana kadar
bilgisayarla
tanışmamış ne olduğu hakkında bir bilgim
yoktu işte
e bilirsiniz o zamanlarda kafayı bir
şeye taktığınız zaman Çevrenizdeki Her
insan onunla ilgilensin istersiniz Daha
doğrusu herkese bunu anlatmaya
çalışırsınız işte benim O zaman aklımda
bir proje vardı bir insan çiziminin e
matematiksel denklemlerle ifade edilmesi
ve farklı parametreler vererek farklı
insanların çiziminin yapıldığı bir
düşünce pratiği vardı Böyle bir kafamda
proje vardı Ben Deniz'e bunları
anlatırken Deniz de bana bilgisayar
programlamayı e öğretiyordu Daha doğrusu
Pardon bilgisayar öğretiyordu sıkıcı
şeyler arkadaşlar 8086 laboratuvarı Eee
Yani henüz Windows cihaz bile görmemişim
işte
eee Yani şöyle söyleyeyim internete
komut satırından girdiğiniz altavista
zamanlı Muhtemelen E çok azınız
duymuştur
Eee İşte o zamanlar Deniz bana işte bir
bilgisayar programı yapıyor benim çok
sevdiğim bir sayı tahmin oyunu var artık
onu ne kadar darlı İsam demiş Hani onu
ben programlayın e ve o programı yazıyor
bana bir gün karşılaştığı mantıksal bir
problemi kod üzerinden anlatmaya başladı
ilk defa bir kod görüyorum çok ilginç
çok zevkli böyle çok heyecanlandım Çünkü
o projeyi Ben aslında böyle yapabilirim
dedim yani böyle hayata geçirebilirim
İşte bu çizim için düşündüğüm şeyi
denize heyecanla Bana Bunu öğret dedim
ve benim işte bu 25 yıllık Hikayem O
noktada o Heyecanın peşinde
başladı Sonra işte bölümlerimiz başladık
hazırlık benim genel olarak böyle
geçti bölümlerimiz başladık bölümlerimiz
işte dersleri ve programlamayı birlikte
götürmeye çalışıyorum şimdi
Eee ama benim Tabii bunu bilerek
seçmedim istatistikte çok temel en temel
bilgisayar programlama dersleri ve
Algoritma dersleri vardı Eee benim için
hani bilinmedik bir bilgiy bu E ben
bütün bilgisayar derslerini aldım Bu
arada Ama ne yazık ki hiçbirinden yeni
bir şey öğrenemedim e Çünkü aslında çok
temel şeyler gösteriliyordu ve ben
aslında o dersleri aldığımda çoktan
bunları öğrenmiş oluyordum Tabii bu
arada ben hani e epey bir kendimi
geliştirmek için kütüphanelerde
laboratuvarlarda sürekli proje
geliştiriyoruz yani hani Eee bu hobi ama
böyle biraz ciddi bir hobi halindeydi
benim için
Eee sonrasında
işte Hatta bazı derslerin hocaları bana
gelirdi ve Yani benim almadığım
derslerin istatistik derslerinin
içerisinde olan bilgisayar programlarını
bana yazdırıyor lardı ya görünen o ki
aslında Ben bölümümden aldığım derslerle
Hani dışarıda mühendis seviyesinde bir
iş yapabilmem mümkün
olmayacaktı Onun için çok daha fazla
çalışmam gerekiyordu İşte ben o zaman ya
o dönemlerde işte Bilgisayar
mühendisliğin ortak olan derslerimizi
orada almaya çalışıyordum ya da işte
ilgimi çeken dersler için hocaların
kapılarını arşınlı oldum ama çok azı
gerçekten bana olumlu bir şekilde dönüş
yapabiliyordu son seneye geldik son sen
sene Ben bilgisayar mühendisliğinden çok
sevdiğim en sevdiğim alan olan
bilgisayar grafiğinin dersini alıyorum
Eee senenin sonlarına doğru sektörün
önde gelen firmalarından bir tanesin
kurucusu
Eee bilgisayar mühendislerle bir oturum
gerçekleştirecek hocamız Beni de davet
etti Ben de tabii ki bütük hevesim le
gittim
Eee bize bir form dağıttılar ne o formda
ne yazıldığını ne sorulduğunu ne de o
hevesli nesın E ne doldurduğunu
hatırlamıyorum ancak ertesi gün
Eee konuşmacının kendisi beni bizzat
telefonla aradı büyük olay nasıl
heyecanlıyım nasıl İnanamıyorum
düşünebilirsiniz yani ben Doğrul attım
Hani gerçekten mi Hani şeklinde
Eee işte yazdıklarımdan çok
etkilendiğini benim gibi öğrencilerle
çalışmak istediklerini Eee ve görüşme
talebini
belirtti Tabii ki ben görüşmeye uçarak
gittim
Eee Nasıl yani olabiliyor muydu böyle
bir şey
eee çok mutlu olmuştum tahmin
edebilirsiniz yani sene sonunda artık
mezun olacağız gittim görüşüyorum Çok
konuşuyorum e anlatacak çok şeyim var
çünkü çok hayallerim var beni bile
aşıyor Hayallerim kendimce
Eee görüşme gayet iyi gidiyor işte onlar
da projeden bahsediyorlar derken e
görüşmenin sonuna doğru benim aldığım
Derslerle ilgili bazı sorular sorulmaya
başladı fark ettim ki beni Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği öğrencisi
tanıyorlar dedim ağız da alışkanlığıyla
yalnız hocam dedim ben dedim İstatistik
Bölümü öğrencisiyim dedim E orada
görüşme sona erdirildi kibar bir şekilde
ve
E yani hayatta başarılar dilenip
yollandım Eee oradaki tek istatistik
öğrencisiydim ve o görüşmeye Yani
çağrılan ilk kişiydim ama E bu şekilde
sonuçlanmıştı Tabii ki yani tahmin
edersiniz o yaştaki bir çocuk olarak
Hani oldukça kötü etkilenmiştim bundan
Ama biliyordum yani bir şeylerin zor
olacağını bu zaten bana bir sürpriz gibi
olmuştu Hani sonrasında işte
hani bu kadar kolay olması zaten benim
için biraz fazla İyi imser neyse mezun
olduk Hatta ben mezun olmadan iş
buldum mutluyum Çünkü yazılım yapıyorum
artık Tam zamanlı yazılım yapıyorum işte
istatistik dersleri bitti
E yani şöyle diyordum Deniz'e
eşime Deniz yazılım yapıyorum üstüne
bana para veriyorlar diyordum Yani o
kadar mutluyum hani çok istediğim bir iş
Hani bu Bununla para kazanabileceğim
Düşünmüyorum yani hani artık Tam zamanlı
olarak bu işi yapabiliyorum Neyse ama Bu
şirketler daha çok otomasyon yazılımları
veri tabanı programlama gibi işler
yapılıyor
buralarda benim o zamana kadar kendimi
geliştirdiğim ve daha çok önne çıkan
şeyim ise aslında oyun programlama
görsel yazılımlar İşte üç boyutlu
yazılımlar Tabii Türkiye'de oyun
sektöründen henüz bahsetmek mümkün değil
Eee Çok
gittik oyun sektöründen henüz bahsetmek
mümkün değil
eee Yani benim en yakın çalışabileceğim
alanlarda simülasyon alanındaki görsel
yazılımlar ben işte Havel san'da o
zamanlar e CN 235 Güney Kore simülatör
projesi Türkiye'nin ilk simülatör
ihracat projesi e duyuruldu e başvurdum
görüşmeye çağrıldım Eee Ama bu sefer
görüşmeye çok daha hazırlıklı
gittim işte sadece sözlerimle değil
artık artık projelerimi de gösterdiğim
bir görüşmenin sonunda bana da güvenen
insanlar sayesinde Eee ilk simülatör
Eee tecrübemi orada girdim havelsan
2003 benim için çok gurur verici bir
şeydi çok mutluydum
e açıkçası 10 yıl geçirdim orada yurt
dışında eğitimler aldığım alanımda
kendimi çok geliştirdiğim E çok güzel
bir tecrübeydi benim için Ama bende
değişmeyen bir şey vardı Eee bu
süreçte oyun programlamaya olan hevesim
bizim Denizli her zaman aktif bir
projemiz olurdu Eee ne kadar işimiz
olursa olsun kendimizi Üzerinde
çalıştığımız bir projemiz evde hep
olurdu Ben 2006 yılında Güney Kore'de
çalışıyordum bir süre bu işte simülatör
projesi için Denizli uzağız işte
internetten görüşüyoruz Aslında şöyle
bir online oyunumuz olsa kendimizin işte
oynasak ne güzel olur Eee falan
fikrinden Çiz bakalım isimli proje
çıkıyor sene 2006 Arkadaşlar şöyle
düşünün henüz sosyal medyanın icat
edilmediği bir dönemde Çiz bakalım
tamamen kulaktan kulağa yayılarak hatra
sayılır bir kitleye ulaştı böyle 500 600
online'' L görüyoruz evde
geliştirdiğimiz bir proje
Eee Çok keyifli bizim için ve şunu ya
orada şöyle söyleyeyim Bir de
sosyalleşen var
eee işte orada tanışanlar evlenenler
bizi düğüne çağıranlar E çok değişik bir
tecrübeydi bizim için yani oyuncular
oyunu sahiplendi ve biz orada şunu
tecrübe ettik insanların sahiplendiği
bir şey yaptığınızda neler
olabileceğini Yani samimi bir şey
yaptığınızda neler olabileceğini biz o
zaman gördük öyle bir tecrübeydi
sonrasında teknoloji gelişiyor Eee Apple
ilk iPhone'u ve de App Store tanıtıyor
App Store
Eee bireysel geliştiriciler için çok
güzel bir yayın Platformu sunuyor Yani
bizim gibi evinde proje geliştiren
İnsanların bu projeleri dünyaya açabilme
Fikri çok heyecan
vericiydi açıkçası
Teşekkürler
Eee çok heyecan vericiydi ve Eee Biz de
hemen bir şeyler yapmak istedik Ama o
zaman Mobil'de yani mobil uygulama
geliştirmek çok yeni bir kavramdır henüz
yeterli kaynak ve
Eee araç geliştirme aracı yoktu Hatta
şöyle söyleyeyim App Store'da e uygulama
geliştirici olmak için Amerika'ya fax
çekiyordum Öyle bir zaman yani öyle
düşünün İşte neyse biz
Eee yine de uğraştık işlerimizden artak
kalan zamanlarda bir şeyler denemeye
başladık bu sefer denemelerimiz Mobil'de
gerçekleştiriyoruz komik replikler
isimli bir uygulama çıkardık komik bir
uygulamaydı deneme yapmak istiyorduk
neler yapabileceğiz bir görmek
istiyorduk yayınland ertesi günü en çok
indirilenler listesinde bir numara oldu
bizim
için acayip heyecan verici bir şeydi
insanlara ulaşabildiğimiz gördük yani
yayınladığımız bir şeyle Yani storun
aslında iyi bir şeyi nasıl öne
çıkardığını gördük Sonra ardından birkaç
oyun denedik Eee onlarla da insanlara
ulaşabiliyoruz e aynı başarıyı onlar da
elde
etti ve dedik ki yani hani bir şeyler
oluyor burada görünür olabiliyoruz
insanlara ulaşabiliyoruz Peki biz Başka
ne yapabiliriz bizim online oyun
tecrübemiz var Eee bütün Türk oyun
şirketlerinin yaptığı gibi biz de bir
okey yaptık deneyelim dedik neler
olabilecek dedik ve çok yeni bir bilgi
bizim için okey mobil reklamlardan para
kazanmaya başladı
bu bizim için yeni bir bilgiy yani çünkü
online oyun mobil reklamla bir iş modeli
kurabileceğimiz fark ettik Bu bizim için
yeni bir bilgi ve bunun üzerinde
düşünmeye başladık başka işte 10151 gibi
türevler de çıkarttık Ama tabii şöyle
bir durum vardı görüyorduk ki artık alan
daralıyordu işte minnetler büyük
firmalar giriyor biz iki mühendis memur
çocukları Yani bizim bir Reklam
harcaması yapabileceğimiz kendimizi
tanıtabilecek
emz yok bizim tamamen farklı bir şeyle
çıkmamız çok elzemdi bu süreçte Ben Eee
son şirketimde çalışıyorum aynı anda üç
proje götürüyorum eee bir oradayım Bir
burada şeklinde sürekli sela çalışıyorum
Akşamları gelip Eee işte kendi işimizle
uğraşıyoruz ve bu işler o zaman
çıkıyor y bir an önce bir şey
çıkartmalıyız Çünkü o zaman hani ilk
olmak çok önemliydi Hani Eee Bu arada
kelimelik Fikri Doğu Türkiye'de Türkçe
bir SCR yapalım dünyada seviliyor çok
mantıklı
dedik ama bunu bir an önce yapmamız
lazım yani saflar biraz sıklaşıyor yani
Kendimizi göstermemiz lazım Bir an
önce dedik ki burada bir ışık gördük biz
bunun arkasından gidelim deneyelim
bakalım ne
olacak tabii mobil reklam üzerine para
kazanan oyun şirketi kurma Fikri
çevredekiler için çok saçma görünüyordu
10 yıllık simülasyon sektörü geçmişini
bir yana bırakacaksın işte
Hatta istifa ettim işte ayrılıyorum son
gün bir arkadaşım bana geldi Emin misin
bak kocan tıklıyor olmasın reklamlara
dedi Gerçekten bu konuşma yaşandı e o
kadar bilinmiyordu yani bu
kavramlar Neyse
Eee ben kocamın tıkladığın emin olarak
çıktım istifa ettim eee ona güvendim En
azından tıklamıyor herhalde Zaten Google
engeller yani Öyle olsa
Eee sonra
işte Kendi işimizi kurduk Evet belki
saçma görünüyordu ama bunu çok
istiyorduk çok zamanlardır bu
hayalimizdi
eee Ben şunu öğrendim hayatım boyunca
İnsan Gerçekten hayatında yaptıklarından
değil yapmadıklarından pişman oluyor Ve
bunu denemek O zaman bizim için çok
elzemdi
ofisimizi kurduk e AE Girmeyeceğim ama
komik bir
yerdeydi bir işte şeyde ufak bir yerde
ötücü ve Sigortacı falan vardı şeyimiz
Herkes bizim ne yaptığımızı merak
ediyordu Hatta bize faks çekmeye falan
geliyorlardı işte fotokopi bizi
bilgisayarcı falan sanıyorlardı ama biz
hiç renk vermiyordu Neyse kurduk
ofisimizi çalışıyoruz kelimelik yoğun
bir çalışma dönemi sonunda 2013 yılınd
Ocak ayında gerçekten yoğun bir çalışma
sonunda çıktı çıktığı ilk günden
beri bizim bu kadarını da beklemediğimiz
çok başarıya imza attı bizi çok mutlu
eden bir proje oldu Tabii bu sırada Biz
online oyun
yönetmenin getirebileceği tüm zorlukları
yaşadık işte sabahın körüne kadar
çalışmalar sabah 5'te sunucu
Güncellemeleri ya da işte artık artan
artan kitleye yanıt vermeyen sistemleri
tamamen yeniden baştan yazmak her türlü
her türlü şekilde karşılaşabileceğimiz
şeyleri gördük Hatta bir güncellememiz o
kadar katastrofik bir hata olmuştu ki
bize binlerce mail geliyordu Bu sırada
hem maillere cevap veriyorduk denizle
Yani iki kişiydik ve hem de işte sorunu
çözmeye çalışıyorduk Böyle zamanlar
geçirdik Tabii kelimelik de büyüdü Biz
de büyüdük ve 10,5 yıllı devirdi 22
milyon insana ulaştı böyle
karşılaştığımız insanların oynadıklarını
duymak Hala bizi mutlu ediyor Mesela
işte kafede restoranda falan insanlar
önümüzde kelimelik oynuyor falan denizle
birbirimize gösterip seviniyoruz
böyle böyle şimdi ben niye bu kadar
baştan anlattım da sizi bu kadar
sıktım Şöyle ki bir alanda başarılı
olmak için illaki o alanın diplomasına
sahip olmanız gerekmiyor istiyorsanız
kimse sizi tutamaz kimse sizin
öğrenmenize engel olamaz hele Bugünlerde
yani bir şey öğrenmek o kadar hani Eee o
kadar çok kaynak var ki biz
kütüphanelerde çok zaman geçirdik
olmayan kitapları Çok bekledik
Eee işte Ama şunu baştan kabul
etmelisiniz Eğer kendinizi Kendi
kendinize geliştiri
olanı bunun için herkesten çok fazla
çalışmanız
gerekiyor ve bunun bir kısa yolu yok Eee
acı bir yol onu baştan söyleyeyim
Eee ama yani herkes bir şeyi yapmak
istediğini söyler Herkes bir şeyi ne
kadar istediğini söyler ama gerçekten
çok azı yapmak istediği şey için gereken
çabayı gösterir Çünkü bu Konfor
alanından çıkmak demektir ve ben gerçek
başarının Ancak bu şekilde elde
edilebileceğini Düşünüyorum şimdi Ay çok
gittik
Eee şimdi Eee şaşırtıcı gelebilir ama
size Ben halen kendimi asıl yapmam
gereken projeyi yapmış gibi
hissetmiyorum Eee son 5 yıldır suluboya
resim yapmaya çalışıyorum eee ve kendimi
bu konuda geliştiriyorum
şimdilerde sulu boya resimlerimle Eee
geliştirdiğim dijital bir oyun yapıyorum
Çok Deneysel bir iş ve şu anda hedefim
yurt dışı neler olabilecek görmek
istiyorum Çok heyecan verici bir Eee
proje benim için
ve artık bitiriyorum bize bu oturumda şu
soruldu kadın teknolojide Örün mü yoksa
üretici mi olacak şeklinde Ben Kadının
her alanda üretici olduğunu düşünüyorum
ve teknolojiyi bundan ayrı
tutmuyorum çevresindeki tüm negatif
seslere kulaklarını kapatıp kadının
yapısı onu bunu yapmaya müsait değildir
diyen tüm seslere kulak kapatıp üreten
ürettikleri le hayatta var olan her
kadının bunun açık kanıtı olduğunu
düşünüyorum teşekkürler